[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول بدعوه من
الرئيس الروسي وصل الى روسيا رئيس الصيني
في اول زياره خارجيه له منذ اعاده انتخابه
للمره الثالثه رئيسا للصين زياره من
المتوقع ان تكون مسائل تطوير العلاقات
الثنائيه والتعاون بين البلدين والوضع
العالمي الراهن على راس جدول الاعمال فيها
وبعد نزوله من الطائره اعرب رئيس الصيني
عن ثقته بان زيارته الى روسيا ستعطي زخما
جديدا للعلاقات مع موسكو وقال الرئيس
الصيني انه مقتنع بان الزياره ستكون مثمره
وستسهم في تطوير سليم ومستقر للعلاقات
الصينيه الروسيه واصفا وموسكو بانهما
جارني جيدان وشركان موثوقان ومضيفا انا
بلاده مستعده لحمايه النظام العالمي وفقا
للقانون الدولي واشار كذلك الى ان اقترح
بيكين بشانه كيفيه التواصل الى تسويه في
اوكرانيا يضع في اعتباره وجهه النظر
العالميه ويسهم في تفادي عواقب الازمه
لكنه اقر بان الحلول قد لا تكون سهله
المبادره الصينيه الشهر الماضي قدمت الصين
وثيقه من 12 نقطه تدعو الى الحوار
والتسويه في اوكرانيا
لكنها لم تتضمن سوى بيانات عامه من دون
اقتراح ملموس لكيفيه انهاء الحرب
اوكرانيا رحبت بتحفظ على الاقتراح الصيني
روسيا العلاقات مع الصين وصلت الى مستوى
تاريخي
الولايات المتحده شككت بشده في اي خطوه
صينيه رفض امريكي قاطع ومسبق لاي مقترح
صيني للهدنه
لقد درسنا بعنايه مقترحاتك لحل الازمه
الحاده في اوكرانيا
ستتاح لنا الفرصه لمناقشه هذه المساله
وسنناقش بالطبع كل هذه القضايا بما في ذلك
مبادرتك بشكل عام ونحن نعلم انك تنطلق من
مبادئ العداله ومراعاه الاحكام الاساسيه
للقانون الدولي انت تدرك ايضا اننا
منفتحون دائما على عمليه التفاوض
وسيسهم تفاعلنا على الساحه الدوليه بالطبع
في تعزيز المبادئ الاساسيه للنظام العالمي
وتعدد الاقطاب
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن طارق
الشامي كاتب محلل السياسي ومن دبي
الهامليه صحفيه الصيني اهلا بكم ضيوفي
الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من واشنطن معك
استاذ طارق استاذ طارق زياره مهمه وصفها
البعض بانها قادره ان تمثل اختراقا حقيقيا
لهذه الازمه هل تعتقد بان زياره الرئيس
الصيني قادره فعليا على تقديم حل حقيقي
للازمه الاوكرانيه
تحياتي لك يا استاذه ريم والدتك الكريم
يعني اعتقد انه هذا يعني يعود الى الصين
ولتفسير النقاط الاثنتي عشر وما الذي
تستطيع بالفعل لتحقيق هذا السلام بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا لانه
المبادره كانت غامضه وعلى الرغم من ترحيب
اوكرانيا بها الا ان الرئيس اليونسكي قال
فيما بعد انه يريد اولا خروج القوات
الروسيه من الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها في
شرق اوكرانيا وهذا يعني ان المبادره ربما
لم تصل الى اي طريق بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
شكوك غربيه وامريكيه بشكل خاص ازاء الدوره
الذي تقوم به الصين لان الصين بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده هي غير محايده هي ساعدت
روسيا على التهرب من العقوبات سواء كان
ذلك بعد عام 2014 حينما سيطرت على شبه
جزيره القرم او بعد حرب اوكرانيا في العام
ثم انها ايضا عززت من تعاونها مع روسيا
بشكل كبير والزياره الحاليه الى موسكو
تؤكد هذا هذه العلاقه الوطيده بين الرئيس
بوتين في حين انه لم يقم باي زياره ممثله
او اعلن عن نياته للقيام بزياره مماثله
الى كييف بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك ايضا
الاعلام الصيني الرسمي هو يتحدث دائما عن
يعني يميل الى تاييد الموقف الروسي يقول
لا يذكر كلمه غزو ولا يذكر كلمه حرب يشير
الى روسيا الى انها يجب وضع في الاعتبار
انها تدافع عن اهتماماتها وخشيتها الامنيه
في جنوب روسيا صحيح ان موقف الصين معروف
وهو عدم
رغبتها في التدخل دوله على اخرى واستخدام
الاليه العسكريه الا انها
السياق العام تؤيد على ما يبدو بالنسبه
للامريكيين تؤيد موقف روسيا بشكل كبير
ولهذا هي لا ترى انها يعني في وضع محايد
مثلما كان عليه الامر حينما توسطت بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبين ايران
ليست محايده الصين تقف الى جانب روسيا
اكثر من وقوفها الى جانب الغرب بحسب ما
شرح بحسب اولا تصريحات الامريكيه وكما شرح
كذلك الاستاذ طارق هل تعتقد بانها عوامل
قد تدفع
بفشل هكذا وساطه
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافتكم واهلا وسهلا بكم
مشاهدين العربيه الحقيقه بالنسبه الى
الصين ان اوافق على رايك نوعا ما بان
الصين تقف على جانب روسيا اكثر من
الدول الغربيه او الجانب الغربي ولكن في
الحقيقه هذا يعتمد على المصالح الاكبر
المشتركه بين الصين وروسيا ولكن في
الحقيقه هذا يعني ان الصين تتمسك في موقف
في نفس الموقع على
الجانب الروسي في شان الازمه الاوكرانيه
خاصه يعني عندما نتكلم عن الازمه
الاوكرانيه فهناك مبادره من قبل الصين حول
حل الازمه الاوكرانيه ففي الحقيقه لاحظنا
ان هناك كلام بين الموقف الصيني والموقف
الروسي ولكن خلاصه قوله بالنسبه لزياره
تفهمت الرئيس الصيني الى روسيا هذه المراه
في الحقيقه يعني لاحظنا ان هناك تسريحه من
قبل جانب الصين ب هذه الزياره تركز على
تعزيز على علاقات الثنائيه اولا ثم
للمساهمه في حل الازمات الدوليه بما فيها
الازمات الاوكرانيه وايضا اللزمات الاخرى
في المناطق لوخرى مثلا في شرق الاوسط في
الحقيقه يعني نحن نعترف بان هناك
مصالح المشتركه كبيره بين الصين وروسيا
وخاصه يعني هناك مصالح مرتبطه بالتجاره
وايضا في مجال الطاقه النظره لتصدير روسيا
لكميه كبيره من النفته وعيده الغاز
الطبيعي الى الصين ولكن في نفس الوقت يعني
الصين تتمسك في نوع ما المحايد تجاه
الازمه الاوكرانيه وخاصه نظرا للمبادره من
قبل الصين
عشر بندا للحل الازمه الاوكرانيه وخصوصا
الاول من ذلك او من تلك المبادره يعني
احترام
بمبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده وهذا مهم جدا
بالنسبه لحل الازمه الفوقانيه اما استاذ
طارق هل تتفق مع ضيفي بان الصين وان كانت
تميل شيئا في موقفها الى الجانب الروسي
ولكن الصين تتعامل
برغماتيه مع هذه المواضيع وتضع المصالح
المشتركه في عين الاعتبار وبالتالي
واقعيتها قادره ان تحدث اختراق معين فيما
يخص هذه الازمه هل تتفق مع هذا الراي او
هذه الرؤيه
نعم اتفق بشكل كبير لانه في حقيقه الامر
هناك قراءات تقول بان الصين ليس في
مصلحتها عقد السلام بين روسيا واوكرانيا
بمعنى اخر هي في مصلحتها ربما كما
الولايات المتحده ان تستمر الحرب لان هذا
سوف يستنزف القدرات العسكريه لدول النيتو
للمخزون العسكري الامريكي باستمرار الحرب
وهي لا تدفع ثمن ذلك الذين يدفعون ثمن ذلك
هم الروس والرئيس بوتين وهي وهذا من شانه
ان يساعد على جعل الراي العام في الولايات
المتحده وفي اوروبا بشكل عام غير متحمس
لان تنخرط يعني ينخرط النيتو والولايات
المتحده في صراع عسكري اخر في شرق اسيا
وبالتحديد حول تايوان في اذا حدث ذلك في
اي وقت في المستقبل وبالتالي هذا جزء كبير
من ربما الاستراتيجيه الصينيه ولهذا هي
ركز على الفكره الاوسع والاجمل وهي الصراع
الجيوسياسي بين الولايات المتحده والنيتو
من جانب وبين الصين وروسيا في التحالف
الاستراتيجي بلا حدود الذي تحدثه عنه
ولكنه في الحقيقه هناك حدود هذه الحدود
واضحه في ان الصين لم تقم حتى الان بتوفير
مساعدات عسكريه الى موسكو رغم الادعاءات
الغربيه بذلك هي ايضا تحرص على انها يعني
او ترى انها الحدود ان هناك يعني
خلافات جيوسياسيه ايضا مع موسكو صحيح ولكن
هو تفسير لما قلته منذ البدايه انت حضرتك
تقول بان الصين لا تود ان تستثمر من جهدها
من
اسلحتها من دعمها لاي طرف من الاطراف
همم فربما كلامك عن عدم البدء بمساعده
الجانب الروسي قد يفهمنا كذلك هذا الطرح
اسمح لي ان انقل هذه النقطه للسيد لسيد لي
هل فعلا بان الصين لن تستثمر في هذه الحرب
ولكن في المقابل كما يقول الاستاذ طارق من
مصلحتها ان تستنزف القوه العسكريه للغرب
نعم في الحقيقه
بان
المصالح صينيه ليس يعتمد على الحرب في اي
مكان في اماكن العالم في الحقيقه يعني
الصين خاسره هذه الحرب او هذه العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه من قبل روسيا على اراضي
الاوكرانيه في الحقيقه يعني كل العالم
يعاني من الخساره بسبب عدم الاستقرار في
الاسواق طاقه وعيده في اسواق الغذاء ولكن
يعني
الصين من مصلحتها ان ترى الغرب يهدر
اسلحته او يستنزف اسلحته في مثل هكذا حرب
وهي تتفرج تحاول ان تتدخل بين الفينه
والاخرى لمحاوله الاصلاح ولكن كذلك
تداعيات هذه الحرب تعود لها لمصلحتها ما
رايك
نعم في الحقيقه يعني كما قلت قبل قليل
التداعيات للازمه الاوكرانيه واسعه النطاق
ولا يمكن ان نقول هناك اي
واحد يعني
الفائزين او نقول يعني
المستفيدين بهذه الحربه الا كتله صغيره من
السياسيين من الولايات المتحده او تجاره
الاسلحه من الولايات المتحده ولكن بشكل
عام مثلا الشعوب في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
عرش المواطنين الامريكان او حتى المواطنين
من الدول الاوروبيه هم الخاسرين
لذلك يعني الصين طرحت مبادره عليه السلام
في حل الازمه الاوكرانيه وخاصه يعني نظرا
للنفوذ الصيني على على روسيا على اوكرانيا
نظره في العلاقات المتينه بين الصين
واوكرانيا فهناك امكانيه لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه بجهود مشتركه بين صيني وايضا
على دول الاوروبيه وطبعا مع الولايات
المتحده ولكن في الحقيقه من المبكره ان
نقول بان الحل
الحل الوحيد بالنسبه للازمه الاوكرانيه
على عيد الصين بان الصين في الحقيقه يعني
لديها تاثيره محدوده جدا لاوكرانيا
بان الحل الوحيد قادر ان ياتي فقط من
الصين
في الحقيقه يعني هذا يعتمد على تحركات من
دول الغربيه وخصوصا من الولايات المتحده
في الحقيقه يعني نظرا لما شاهدنا في
الايام الاخيره في شرق الاوسط او خصوصا
فتبيع الحلقات بين السعوديه
وايران في الحقيقه يعني هناك حلول مختلفه
من قبل الصين ولكن هل تعلم سيد لي بان
البعض يقول بان الصين لما تدفع بنفسها الى
هكذا وسطات هي عينها على قياده النظام
العالم ما رايك سيد طارق في هذه الفقره هل
يمكن للصين ان تحل محل واشنطن هل يمكن ان
تحل محل واشنطن في قياده النظام العالمي
وهل هي قادره على ذلك
بلا شك هي تسعى الى ذلك لكن هذا لن يعني
لن يكون سهلا بالمره يعني بالتاكيد ما
قاله حتى الرئيس الصيني في مقال نشر في
صحيفه روسيه اليوم هو تحدث عن اهميه تعزيز
العلاقات مع روسيا لمواجهه التحديات
الامنيه المشتركه وما يصفه بسياسات
الهيمنه في اشاره واضحه الى الولايات
المتحده بالتاكيد هذا هو يعني الجزء
الاساسي في الاستراتيجيه الصينيه وهي
مواجهه الهيمنه الامريكيه او ما تصفه
بالهيمنه الامريكيه بالتعاون مع روسيا
روسيا دوله ايضا
شاشات شاشات المساحه وهي ايضا تمتلك من لا
تمتلك الصين من اسلحه نوويه استراتيجيه
وهي تصدر للصين الاسلحه المتقدمه في
المقابل ايضا الصين تساعد روسيا وبالتالي
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بينهما كبيره ومن
المرجح سوف تستمر لكن هذا لا يعني انا
الولايات المتحده يعني لن تستطيع مواجهه
ذلك نحن نرى التحالفات التي تزيد كل يوم
بين الولايات المتحده وحلفائها ليس فقط في
حلف الناتو وانما ايضا في شرق اسيا مع
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه بل ومع الهند
واستراليا وما الى ذلك كل هذا يؤشر بان
هذا هو الصراع الحقيقي وليست حرب اوكرانيا
سوى جزء من هذا الصراع والعين الان هي ما
الذي سوف يحصل في تايوان مع تعزيز مزيد من
الاليات العسكريه والسفن الحربيه
الامريكيه في شرق في شرق الصين اكيد
تطورات ستفهمنا اكثر عن كل هذه المواقف
ولنقاش دائما بقيه اود شكركم جزيل الشكر
طارق الشاميه الكاتب والمحلله السياسي ومن
دبي الهاملي الصحفي الصيني شكرا لكمما